et l'argent qui fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
la situation politique d'abord c'est
quoi votre analyse de cette espèce de
tsunami
les choses commencent à s'organiser plus
entre deux poules ou trois peut-être la
france elle est entre la droite et
l'extrême droite on peut pas éviter ce
constat la situation politique va se
passer à droite et sur des thématiques
de droite ça veut dire par exemple que
votre candidate est obligé de durcir ses
positions de droite l'idée de ces
primaires internes c'était de créer à
l'arrivée l'équipe de france et l'équipe
de france elle est là c'est la première
fois première fois dans l'histoire de
france qu'une femme selon les sondages
peut être élue présidente de la
république c'est sans doute une
révolution qui permet de dire que le
plafond de verre a peut être enfin
exploser
[Musique]
plus de 91 mille cas de contamination en
24 heures un record en france depuis
mars 2020 une cinquième vague qui
devrait s'aggraver dans les prochains
jours au micro n'étant plus contagieux
et résistant aux vaccins un conseil de
défense sanitaire aura lieu lundi en
présence d'emmanuel macron à des mesures
de restriction supplémentaire pourrait
être annoncé
au micro ondes qui touche fortement les
états unis également malgré la
propagation du variant des millions
d'américains vont fêter noël à travers
tout le pays sur recommandation de joe
biden elle qui appelle ses compatriotes
à le célébrer le plus normalement
possible tout en respectant les gestes
barrière pourtant les hôpitaux sont au
bord de l'asphyxié
[Musique]
en tunisie le président guéi sayyed a
mis en garde contre des tentatives
d'assassinât ciblant sa propre personne
et des haut fonctionnaires
fonctionnaires les menace émanerait
d'après lui de ses opposants aussi bien
à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du pays
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france près de six cent
mille français vont passer noël isolé
soit près de 1% de la population
nationale et des fêtes de fin d'année
assombries par omicron face à la
propagation du variant plus contagieux
et plus résistants aux vaccins emmanuel
macron annonce la tenue d'un conseil de
défense ce lundi un conseil des
ministres aura lieu dans la foulée des
nouvelles restrictions sont envisagées
la situation pour un effet se dégrade et
honey bee tarot juliette la vie
c'est le grand jour les français font
leurs derniers achats et s'apprête à
fêter noël dans un contexte sanitaire
grave certains le passeront même à
l'isolément depuis le 16 décembre plus
de six cent mille personnes ont été
testées positives
alors pour limiter les risques beaucoup
ont anticipé cette semaine détient le
record du nombre de dépistages
avec plus de 6 2 millions de
prélèvements réalisés
on n'a pas trop chaud finalement c'est
la santé qui prime d'abord donc on fait
le test puis
mais c'est pas on n'est pas très
enthousiaste à l'idée fêter noël comme
nous serons
six sept huit personnes on se fait un
test anti génique autre record également
celui des contaminations du côté des
hôpitaux le personnel soignant est sur
le pied de guerre car en cette période
de fêtes les effectifs sont réduits
actuellement nous avons 12 et de
réanimation d'ouvert et quatre lits du
vc unité de surveillance continue dû
fermer pour prendre des personnels
deux lits de surveillance continue
pendant cette période 2
de noël nous avons à l'heure actuelle
cette passion qu vide qu'ils sont
tous sont vaccinés et qui sont des
copies qui sont graves non pas parce que
dans les sept patients il y en a six qui
sont intubés ventiler la propagation du
virus pourrait même atteindre plusieurs
centaines de milliers de cas par jour en
janvier selon le conseil scientifique et
elle pourrait entraîner une
désorganisation des services essentiels
l'instance s'inquiète également des
éventuelles répercussions dans les
services accueillant du public
il faut s'attendre à une désorganisation
possible d'un certain nombre de services
essentiels en janvier à cause de
l'absentéisme et des arrêts de travail
dus au très grand nombre de
contaminations à omicron pour l'heure
aucune restriction supplémentaire n'est
envisagé le gouvernement continue de
miser sur sa stratégie vaccinale ce
vendredi la haute autorité de santé a
même recommandé de réduire le délai de
la dose de rappel à trois mois mais le
gouvernement préfère le maintenir à
quatre mois et parmi les nouvelles
restrictions possiblement annoncé lundi
le gouvernement étudie la possibilité
d'exiger un test négatif en plus du pass
vaccinale pour accéder à certains lieux
publics dans le même temps la haute
autorité de santé recommande de réduire
à trois mois le délai pour la dose de
rappel les vaccins seraient moins
efficaces dans la durée contre ce
nouveau variant dans son dernier avis
publié ce matin est l'instance
scientifique préconise également à
d'élargir la campagne de rappel aux
adolescents fragiles âgées de 12 à 17
ans
en europe des mesures sont d'ores et
déjà mises en application pour tenter
d'endiguer l'épidémie un confinement
annulation des festivités du nouvel an
ou retour du port du masque à
l'extérieur comme en grèce masque
obligatoire dans la rue mais aussi dans
tous les lieux publics au moins jusqu'au
3 janvier face à l'augmentation du
nombre de cas au mikron dans le pays
plusieurs événements dont des camps ce
des concerts ont été annulés
[Musique]
une fois nous sommes libres une fois
nous sommes enfermés nous ne faisons que
suivre les ordres
je crois qu'il faut juste coopérer et
être de nouveau tous ensemble
cette recrudescence de l'épidémie
impacte fortement les compagnies
aériennes plus de 2000 vols dans le
monde dont près d'un quart aux états
unis ont été adulés le début de l'année
2022 s'annonce compliquée alors que le
pire semblait être passé rémy savary
nouvelles turbulences pour le secteur
aérien européen
face aux restrictions imposées par les
pays et la propagation du variant
omicron certaines compagnies sont
obligées d'agir à l'image de lufthansa
la compagnie allemande a décidé
d'annuler 33 mille vols soit 10% de son
programme hivernal en cause une forte
baisse des réservations et un manque de
personnel les liaisons transatlantiques
vers l'amérique du nord vers boston
houston et washington sont
principalement affecté du 23 au 26
décembre en raison de l'augmentation du
taux de maladies chez les pilotes des
annulations qui coûte cher à
l'entreprise en 2020 déjà le géant du
transport européen avait connu des
pertes record et en mars dernier il
avait annoncé une perte nette de 6,7
milliards d'euros chez ryanair la vague
fait aussi des dégâts sur le nombre de
réservations la compagnie irlandaise
indique que sa perte annuelle devrait
être le double de ce qu'elle attendait
du côté d'air france le son de cloche
semble différent il n'y a pas de vague
d'annulations mais un petit
ralentissement des réservations
on est plutôt dans une logique de
réservation à court voire très court
terme les clients reviennent à une
situation d'attentisme ne se projette
pas sur l'avenir ce jeudi l'association
des aéroports européens aci europe a
exprimé son inquiétude ces prévisions
lui font craindre un effondrement de 20%
du trafic passagers chez ses adhérents
une estimation qu'elle a pu construire à
partir du 24 novembre la date
l'identification du variant omicron en
afrique du sud cette nouvelle version du
virus aurait un effet repoussoir évident
selon didier bréchemier spécialiste du
secteur aérien au sein du cabinet roland
berger les informations sur la plus
grande contagiosité du variant génère
une certaine peur de revoir âgés tandis
que les règles hétérogène selon les pays
engendre une vraie complexité du côté
d'euros contrôle on remarque malgré tout
certains indicateurs à la hausse
l'organisation européenne pour la
sécurité de la navigation aérienne
indique que la fréquentation au début de
la saison de noël avait augmenté de 9%
sur une semaine une hausse qui reste
passagère selon olivier jean covec
directeur général de l'organisation
seuls les voyages pour rendre visite à
la famille et aux amis tiennent plus ou
moins le coup une fois les vacances
terminées il ne fait aucun doute qu'au
micro on aura des conséquences adverses
sur le trafic des passagers lors du
premier trimestre de 2022 des compagnies
aériennes régie par des choix
gouvernementaux un nouveau trou d'air
pour tout un secteur qui a déjà connu un
véritable crash économique au royaume
uni le variant omicron bat des records
plus de 122 mille cas enregistrés en 24
heures un chiffre inédit outre-manche
dans son traditionnel message de noël
le premier ministre britannique
exhortent ses concitoyens à se faire
vacciner même si la pression
hospitalière reste stable et barry
johnson prévient il n'hésitera pas à
serrer la vis si la situation sanitaire
se dégrade
après deux ans de cette pandémie je ne
peux pas dire que nous en sommes sortis
comment le pourrais-je quant au micro
déferle quand nous sommes tous au
courant nous devons ensemble essayer
d'arrêter la propagation de ce nouveau
variant nous devons nous tester et
redoubler de prudence lorsque nous
rencontrons des personnes âgées ou des
personnes vulnérables
nous savons que les choses restent
difficiles il y a encore une chose
merveilleuse que vous pouvez offrir à
votre famille à tout le pays et c'est de
recevoir le vaccin qu'il s'agisse de
votre premier ou de votre deuxième ou de
votre rappel afin que les festivités de
l'année prochaine soit encore meilleure
que celle de cette année un tour de vis
déjà enclenché en équateur la
vaccination est désormais obligatoire
contre le coc u19 dès l'âge de 5 ans une
première mondiale pour cette catégorie
d'âge à seule une poignée de pays ont
rendu obligatoire mais pour les
personnes majeures à près de 70% de la
population est pourtant vacciner une
décision prise pour faire face à
l'arrivée est de mikron mathieu les
kings chercheur à l'institut des hautes
études nationales de quito nuance le
caractère dit obligatoire de la
vaccination en équateur le mob ligue at
war et est un peu
et par totalement véridique que l'on va
dire
c'est une hyène vaccination obligatoire
si les gens veulent sortir dans des
lieux publics alors c'est pas
obligatoire par exemple pour aller à
l'école pour le travail pour les
hôpitaux
c'est obligatoire pour aller dans un bar
des concerts musées en gros tout ce qui
est
espaces publics fermés on va dire et en
plus le gouvernement ne va pas
sanctionner la personne mais
l'établissement c'est à dire si
l'établissement ne fait pas ne contrôle
pas à l'entrée c'est l'établissement qui
est sanctionnée par la personnes non
vaccinées donc
rien de nouveau par rapport à d'autres
pays comme en europe aux etats unis ou
où l on retrouve finalement ce genre de
mesure non
plus au nord de l'équateur les états
unis justement n'envisage pas de mesures
supplémentaires malgré une pression ou
hospitalières assez intense au
washington devrait même levé les
restrictions de voyage le 31 décembre
prochain qui pèsent sur plusieurs pays
africains à lens ce vendredi de la
maison blanche à l'intérieur du pays les
voyages se multiplient également malgré
la vague de contaminations aux variants
omicron yamina benguigui dans
certains sous sur le départ d'autres
arrivent comme ici à la gare de
washington
en cette période de fêtes plus de 109
millions d'américains voyage à travers
les états unis par avion train ou en
voiture
malgré l'avancée fulgurante du vario
mikron
[Musique]
c'est vraiment frustrant parce qu'on
avait prévu ces vacances depuis des mois
et qu'il ya quelques semaines on a
appris que le variant au micro n'était
plus important est qu'il continuait à se
propager et à ce stade c'est plus
difficile pour nous de tout annuler et
de perdre de l'argent que de faire de
notre mieux pour nous protéger
c'est toujours un peu inquiétant mais
heureusement avec le vaccin la situation
semble plus facile à gérer
et les raisons de voyager sont variées
certains font le choix stratégique de
fuir des états où le respect des
restrictions sanitaires et le moins
appliquée c'est le cas de cette mère de
famille qui quittent miami pour new york
beaucoup de masques sont enlevés les
gens ne suivent pas vous savez ne
veulent pas porter de masque et oui donc
donc je me sens plus en sécurité ici en
fait même s'il ya plus de monde en plus
des voyageurs qui veulent limiter les
risques pour éviter d'attraper le virus
et de contaminer leurs proches en retour
ils sont plus d'un million d'américains
à s'être fait injecter une dose de
rappel en 24 heures mais ils sont aussi
nombreux à opter pour le dépistage comme
ici sur ce nouveau site à new york où
l'on distribue des tests rapides à faire
à domicile même si je suis vacciné je
sais qu'on peut toujours être porteurs
du virus alors j'essaye simplement de
m'assurer que je n'expose pas
inutilement d'autres personnes surtout
en ce moment pendant les vacances et en
hiver où on est tous les uns sur les
autres mais les boosters shot et le
dépistage ne sont pas suffisants face à
la vague au micron près de 40% des
américains ne sont pas complètement
vaccinés
les cas augmentent et avec eux les
hospitalisations à apple valley en
californie cet hôpital déjà submergées
se prépare à un nouveau pic une tante
provisoire a été installée sur le
parking pour traiter les patients à
l'intérieur de l'établissement certains
d'entre eux sont installés sur des lits
dans les couloirs faute de chambres
disponibles
nous sommes excessivement épuisé ça
commence à ressembler à l'année dernière
à la même époque maintenant vous savez
ça commence à me rappeler l'année
dernière c'est un genre de syndrome post
traumatique prêter assez saturé avec 171
milka quotidiens en moyenne ces derniers
sept jours aux états unis la vague
provoquée par le variant omicron déjà
largement dominant est sur le point de
dépasser celle du ovarian delta mais le
président américain quant à lui
relativise joe biden recommande à ses
compatriotes de ne pas paniquer les
invitant à célébrer noël comme prévu en
évitant simplement laid trop gros
rassemblement on reste aux etats unis
les événements du capital sont encore
dans tous les esprits près d'un an après
alors qu'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire poursuit ses
investigations en ciblant la donald
trump est bien ce dernier a annoncé la
tenue d'une conférence de presse 6
janvier prochain un an jour pour jour
après les violences qui se sont
produites à washington on en parle tout
de suite avec notre correspondant aux
états unis thomas bonnin
thomas bonsoir alors pourquoi donald
trump peut-il prendre la parole en ce
jour particulier
et bien parce qu'il contexte il conteste
le narratif qui est exposée dans les
principaux médias américains autour de
cette journée du 6 janvier on sait aussi
qu'un certain nombre de ses proches ont
refusé de se rendre à des auditions de
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire et cette semaine donald
trump a même saisi la cour suprême des
états unis pour demander à ce qu'elle
bloque le transfert de ces documents
datant de l'époque où il était à la
maison blanche à destination de cette
commission d'enquêté qui donc donald
trump a organisé une conférence de
presse ce sera le 6 janvier prochain à
mar à lago en floride il devrait répéter
les messages qu'il martèle depuis
maintenant des mois à savoir qu'il
estime que cette commission denquête et
partisane et donc biaisé écoutez un
extrait du communiqué publié par donald
trump
pourquoi le comité des politiciens
partisane enquête il pas sur les causes
de la manifestation du 6 janvier à
savoir l'élection truquée de 2020 est ce
que quelqu'un a remarqué qu'ils veulent
se tenir le plus éloigné possible de ce
sujet les chiffres ne vont pas dans leur
sens où même son approche
la seule chose qu'ils peuvent faire
c'est de ne pas en parler
alors conséquences ou pas de cette
conférence de presse qui va être
organisé par donald trump la maison
blanche a annoncé depuis que joe biden
aussi allé prendre la parole le 6
janvier prochain on ne sait pas encore
exactement sous quelle forme ce qu'on
sait en revanche c'est que les
démocrates du congrès prévoit une
journée spéciale pour l'occasion malgré
le fait est qu'il n'y ait pas de travaux
parlementaires prévues à l'agenda pour
le 6 janvier les démocrates autour de
nancy pelosi ont déjà un programme
spécifiquement prévu pour cette journée
avec notamment à des veillées une
veillée de prière et des prises de
parole sous la forme de témoignage de
parlementaires qui était au capitole le
6 janvier dernier
merci beaucoup thomas bonnet pour toutes
ces précisions en direct de washington
dans le même temps la maison blanche
hausse de nouveau le ton contre la chine
at the bride n a validé cette nuit une
loi qui interdit l'importation de
produits fabriqués pour les ouigours
mesures qui visent à lutter contre le
travail forcé de la minorité
musulmane en chine pour je cite mettre
fin au génocide et crimes contre
l'humanité
pékin rapidement réagi en accusant les
états unis de violer le droit
international
françois xavier lambert
one gauche cet acte dénigre
malicieusement la situation des droits
de l'homme dans le zig zhang chinois au
mépris des faits et de la vérité il
viole gravement le droit international
et les normes fondamentales régissant
les relations internationales et
interfère grossièrement dans les
affaires intérieures de la chine la
chine le déplore et le rejette fermement
les prétendus allégations de travail
forcé de génocide within jiang ne sont
que des mensonges vicieux concocté par
les forces antichinoises eu d'autres
organes
on enchaîne avec le gazoduc north stream
ii qui doit acheminer du gaz russe en
allemagne via la mer baltique toujours
au coeur des discussions berlin a mis en
garde il pourrait y avoir de sévères
conséquences selon le comportement de la
russie envers l'ukraine ont fait le
point avec notre correspondant à moscou
antoine gayraud le projet nord stream ii
a tout d'abord connu des difficultés au
moment de sa construction ralentie par
les sanctions américaines depuis la fin
du chantier il faut désormais attendre
le feu vert des autorités allemandes
d'abord attendu en fin de cette année
puis repoussée à début 2011 22 on a
appris il ya quelques jours que ce ne
serait pas avant le milieu de l'année
prochaine et ce alors qu'une crise
énergétique frappe l'europe manière
poutine a commenté la situation en
prenant en particulier le cas de
l'ukraine tentant de sigatoka doit en ce
qui concerne north stream 2 et je suis
d'accord avec vos évaluations
c'est d'autant plus bête pour ceux qui
ne laisse pas ce système fonctionne et
parce que l'arrivée des volumes de gaz
supplémentaires sur le marché européen
je ferais sans aucun doute baisser le
prix à la bourse le prix spot
parce qu'aucun geste
comme de nombreux pays dont même
l'ukraine dépendent du prix spot
aujourd'hui c'était leur choix
ils ne veulent pas acheter à nous
directement le prix aurait chuté pour
eux
que chez ceux mais il mordille
littéralement la main qui les nourrit
c'est surprenant mais bon c'est leur
choix ce n'est pas nous qui l'avons
décidé ce sont deux
en effet l'ukraine paye actuellement son
gaz au prix fort alors qu'une partie du
gaz russe transitent via le territoire
ukrainien ce qui représente une source
de revenus importante pour kiev avec la
mise en service de nord stream 2
l'ukraine et ses alliés occidentaux
craignent que la russie abandonne peu à
peu la voix ukrainienne et se servent
donc du gaz comme d'une arme
géopolitique ce que moscou réfute qui
plus est dans le contexte de tension
maximale entre la russie d'un côté et
l'ukraine de l'autre l'union européenne
et les etats unis ont menacé les
continue de menacer moscou deux
sanctions en particulier sur north
stream 2
si la situation venait à empirer
regarde tensions en tunisie
le président kaïs ayed met en garde
contre une tentative d'assassinât contre
sa personne et des haut fonctionnaires
et des menaces qui viendrait selon lui
directement de ses opposants aussi bien
à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du pays
le chef de l'état est de plus en plus
isolé depuis son coup de force du 25
juillet dernier date à laquelle au nom
de la lutte contre la corruption il a
gelé le parlement et limoger le
gouvernement les détails avec notre
correspondant à tunis va c'est mme
shelly un conseil des ministres aux
allures de réunion de crise hier soir
palais de carthage entouré des membres
du gouvernement le président de la
république a mis en garde son équipe et
l'ensemble de la population tunisienne
contre d'éventuels projets d'assassinât
organisé par ce qu'il qualifie de
traître après être revenu sur ses
projets de réformes et sa lutte contre
la corruption le chef de l'état assuré
sur un ton ferme qu'il était au courant
de l'ensemble des complots préparer à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur du
territoire évoquant des tentatives
visant à faire échouer son projet pour
la tunisie écoutez je le dis devant tout
le monde il y à des complots qui se
trament et qui vont jusqu'à la
suggestion d'assassinât les tunisiens
doivent être vigilants et attentifs aux
plans trafiquées par certains traître
vendu aux services de renseignement pour
exécuter un nombre de responsables nous
savons ce qui se trame à l'intérieur et
à l'étranger nous sommes au courant de
l'existence d'un appel téléphonique qui
évoque la date même de ces assassinats
depuis son coup de force du 25 juillet
la mise en place des mesures
exceptionnelles est les rangs de
l'opposition gonfle jour après jour
discréditant davantage à l'action du
président de la république qu'il soit de
la société civile ou de la classe
politique tous dénoncent une violation
des libertés et des acquis de la
révolution de 2011 par un homme qui
centralise à lui seul tous les pouvoirs
l'organisation internationale human
rights watch a mis en garde contre
certaines violations flagrantes des
libertés à commencer par la
multiplication des procès militaires et
civils pour offense au président écoute
et critiqué publiquement le président
suite à son accaparement de pouvoirs
additionnels c'est prendre le risque de
finir devant un tribunal faire taire les
critiques représente un double danger à
l'heure où le président est occupé à
concentrer tant de pouvoirs entre ses
mains
faisant fi de toute critique l homme
fort de la tunisie et bien décidé à
maintenir son cap dans un pays qui
s'enlise davantage dans une crise
économique et politique sans précédent
plus de trente ans après l'invasion
irakienne du koweït bagdad a fini je te
payer toutes les réparations de guerre
qui lui avait été imposé cette semaine
une somme de plus de 50 milliards de
dollars au total les explications en
images
cinquante 2,4 milliards de dollars c'est
le montant total remboursé par l'irak au
koweït selon le conseiller économique du
premier ministre irak à bagdad a refermé
le dossier des réparations liées à la
guerre la banque centrale irakienne
avait annoncé le versement mardi de la
dernière tranche qui s'élevait à 44
millions de dollars
c'est faux avait été validé par la
commission de compensation des nations
unies établi en 1991 il provenait d'une
taxe de 5 % prélevée sur les ventes de
pétrole irakien
ces remboursements avait été suspendue
en 2014 alors que le gouvernement de
bagdad se focaliser sur la guerre contre
les djihadistes du groupe etat islamique
les autorités irakiennes avaient repris
les versements en 2018 après avoir
remporté la victoire ces compensations
sont distribués à de nombreux
destinataires koweïtien des personnes
privées des sociétés ou encore des
organisations qui toutes ont subi des
pertes directement liés à l'invasion et
à l'occupation irakienne
cette première guerre du golfe avait été
provoqué par l'envahissement du koweït
en août 1990 par les troupes irakiennes
sur fond de tensions liées au prix du
pétrole en réplique la coalition
internationale menée par les américains
était intervenu en février 1991 la
victoire avait été écrasante
pendant 40 jours les combats auraient
tué près de quarante mille civils et
près de cent mille soldats irakiens
selon certaines estimations
mais au tueur bilan définitif n'a été
communiqué retour en france lors de son
interview bilan du 15 décembre emmanuel
macron cecily sites et d'un taux de
chômage historiquement bas sur le
territoire français pourtant des
syndicalistes de pôle emploi elle reste
un tableau moins brillants de la
politique du gouvernement lucas légers
dans une période de reprise économique
louée par la macro ni la tolérance ton a
baissé envers les chômeurs la semaine
dernière un sondage et lab publié pour
l'unedic montrer que les français
avaient un regard plus dur sur les
demandeurs d'emploi 48% des personnes
interrogées considéraient que la plupart
des chômeurs ne cherche pas vraiment
retrouver un emploi et 43% estimé que
les demandeurs d'emploi sont
responsables de leur situation deux taux
en hausse depuis les dernières enquêtes
d'opinion sur le même sujet dans son
allocution du 9 novembre emmanuel macron
n'a pas hésité à pointer du doigt les
demandeurs d'emploi qui ne jouent pas le
jeu alors que l'exécutif faisait valoir
que des centaines de milliers d'offres
d'emploi
restait à pourvoir les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne démontreront pas une
recherche active verront leurs
allocations suspendues dans la foulée
elisabeth bornes annoncé une
intensification des contrôles plus deux
cent cinquante mille procédure sur six
mois pour atteindre 500 milles en 2022
au total contre quatre cent mille en
2019 on va intensifier les contrôles et
c'est bien normal alors qu'on accompagne
comme on ne l'a jamais fait les
demandeurs d'emploi qu'on a proposé des
formations là aussi comme on n'a jamais
fait qu'on assure que les demandeurs
d'emploi cherche effectivement du
travail mais pour des professionnels de
pôle emploi interrogé par l'humanité la
situation est loin d'être aussi simple
que ça on n'arrête pas de nous parler de
ses 200 milles à 300 mille offres non
pourvues sur ces professions où il est
difficile de recruter mais on oublie
souvent de dire que les conditions de
travail sont pourris et les salaires bas
après avoir été mise de côté au plus
fort de la crise du coc vite dit 9 entre
le deuxième et le troisième trimestre
2000 21 les radiations sont repartis sur
les chapeaux de roues pour revenir aux
niveaux d'avant la crise mais cette
logique de contrôle renforcées ne plaît
guère aux syndicats de pôle emploi qui
pourrait mener une action en début
d'année prochaine c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes en attendant restez
bien avec nous sur rtl france
[Musique]
je il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire que le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie d'avoir
un huitième
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter